but if i just showed a fetch a party
would you have me
would you want me anyone would want
taylor swift at their party
the singer's performance of betty was a
standout moment during the 2020 academy
of country music awards only 17
i don't know anything e.t was actually
with taylor when she was 17
at her first acm awards in 2007.
i skipped out on prom this year so this
is uh this is my chance to feel like a
princess for this year
this was taylor's first appearance at
the acm awards in
seven years and e.t learned she was even
her own personal glam squad
doing her own hair and makeup before
taking the stage in head to toe stella
mccartney
i saw the announcement with with taylor
doing a doing a performance just when i
thought i was going to have the most
viewed section of the show
fellow performer luke bryant echoed the
excitement leading up to taylor's big
moment
you know i think taylor coming you know
heck it's taylor swift i mean you know
she's
such an amazing person and really
defined
set the tone of how you ought to treat
your fans and how you ought to work hard
in this business
in another crossover moment keith urban
and pink performed their duet one too
many for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
keith also served as a host of the acm
awards and his supportive wife nicole
kidman was seen on social media
cheering him on from australia i want to
send a shout out to my girls too nicole
mary
sunny and thief watching at home tonight
i love you guys and i miss you
nicole even took to instagram to say she
was so excited for his duet with pink
i can't wait people to get to hear this
keith told et how their song came
together
all right tell me about too many with
pink your voices blend together so
beautifully in this song thank you it
was great getting to do a song with her
i've been a
such a deep admirer of her gift and her
as a person too
her entire career she's extraordinary i
mean she's got the she's got the
the career to prove it she's an
extraordinarily gifted human being
that voice
you know at the second it comes on you
just know it she's one of the greats
she literally is one of the greats and
getting to do a song with her was
amazing